okay good evening ladies and gentlemen i
make that six o'clock so we will begin
the meeting now my name is councillor
peter richards welcome to i'll be
chairing tonight's meeting welcome to
the planning uh committee meeting on the
8th of december 2021. um a few
housekeeping things if i may to start
with uh mobile phones if you could
please turn them off that would be
preferable if you must have them on
please have them on silent i don't mind
you using them just as long as they
don't disrupt the flow of the meeting
um
we aren't expecting to have a fire alarm
so if it does go off don't panic please
follow us out to the car park at the
front and we will make sure everyone has
exited the building safely before you
are sent on your way back home um the
meeting itself is a meeting in public it
is not a public meeting so only those
that have registered speak will be
allowed to speak
you will be
called forward excuse me
we're gonna try a different microphone
to
see if that helps can everyone still
hear me okay
this is fun
um
marvelous
i i'd say yeah so meeting in public not
a public meeting so any of those
directions to speak can we call you
forward at the appropriate time uh if
you take a seat at either
are we going to get feedback
a little bit
okay we're going to try try and crack on
so if you take a seat at either desk in
front of you doesn't matter which one
hopefully your microphones will work
it's the button in the middle it will go
red when you're ready to speak um when
you finish speaking uh if you could
please grab one of the wipes give the
desk a quick wipe down uh same on the
microphone and
use the the gel on your hands there is a
bin as cancer edna's kindly placed for
us to put any of the wipes in afterwards
um okay
we're also being live streamed and
recorded for future viewing on our uh
website and on youtube as well just so
you're aware
let's go for some introductions so
on my far right we have liz jaworska
from our committee services to my
immediate right we have mason nash who
is our solicitor and our planners in no
particular order are alison frost
allison willis paul thompson sarah
chadwick and to my immediate left is
richard gardner who's our planning
manager richard i think you've got a
statement to make please
thank you mr chairman uh just to confirm
that my role tonight is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
thank you very much right let's start
the agenda proper so apologies for
absence first please liz
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam crump foreman and
kendall this evening
thank you very much and any disclosures
of interest i am going to kick us off i
am the ward member on the first item
that is the uh tree preservation order
and i've registered to speak so i will
be vacating the chair and and be able uh
replaced by councillor fleming do you
have any other disclosures councillor
fleming
okay thank you very much any others
council curtis and i think we probably
all had emails about the our first item
on the agenda this evening
okay i'm seeing a lot of nodding so i
will take that as a blanket disclosure
anything else members
no okay in that case i'm going to vacate
the chair and pass over to council
fleming who will introduce the first
item
thank you right
item one
is uh tpo
084-010
it's a tree preservation order on the
boundary of snitterfield sports club and
a new house in wolverton road
snitterfield
i'll move to the first
to
the officer
alison frost
thank you chad
so this evening we're asking members to
consider the confirmation or not
of a provisional tree preservation order
that is currently in place at
snettersfield sports club
you can see the location on that slide
there's also
the formal tpo plan
sorry it's a bit small scale
and
a photograph to follow
it's a relatively young oak tree and
it's growing on the boundary of
snitterfield sports club and new house
it's approximately
50 to 60 years old
the tpo was served on it this summer to
retain this amenity oak tree
provisionally
it's currently a healthy amenity site
feature it has good public immunity
and being an oak tree it has long-term
potential
a new sports club together with some
enabling residential development is
currently under consideration
the planning application is yet to be
determined
but the provisional tpo
protection on this oak tree expires next
week hence we're considering it tonight
importantly future planning at
permission could override a tpo in the
future if that is what is decided
formal objections to the tpo were
submitted from the sports club in the 28
period after the tpo was served as per
the legislation
these formal objections have to be
considered before a tpo is confirmed by
the council
responses to each of these points are
made in the report but in summary the
sports club said
the sports club is a vital village asset
the site was in the neighborhood plan
for up to nine homes
this could make a planning application
unviable
i don't think anyone would disagree with
it being a vital village asset but all
this would be carefully weighed up in
the future decision on the current
planning application
and we think the oak tree is worthy of
protection in the meantime as part of
that overall consideration
they mentioned the tree may be causing
subsidence to the existing coloured
building
no detailed evidence of this was
submitted
however their current planning
application proposes to demolish and
relocate this building
so again until the outcome of the
planning application is decided it
doesn't seem right to remove protection
of this oak tree at this currently
slightly premature stage
but if the proposed sports club and the
housing development doesn't go ahead
then if detailed evidence is submitted
there's no fee it would go through the
usual consent for works to protected
trees process the council to assess
they stated it would threaten the large
mature oak tree on the opposite side of
the road
we disagree
it's not a threat it's a different age
of tree different side of the road and
it could be quite a nice gateway feature
their final objections said they were
planting 200 young trees elsewhere on
the site with snitterfield tree action
group as part of the planning
application
whilst this is very commendable there is
no provision with tpo regs to allow for
offsetting of other planting as a
substitute for retaining a mature
existing tree such planting is likely to
be necessary as part of their planning
application
but not instead of a tpo doctrine
finally for members information the
modification mentioned on the front page
is just to a tpo reference number it's a
typo it should be 713.173
and such minor changes are permitted by
the regs
if members decide to confirm the tpo
we would ask to correct that number
overall officers would recommend that
the tpo is still confirmed to prevent
premature works or loss to this oak tree
before a decision has been reached
regarding the proposed sports club and
the enabling housing planning
application
it doesn't require the sports club to do
anything and it doesn't prevent them
from doing anything in the future
it means consent would be needed for
failing or pruning work until members
have made their decision on the current
planning application which will be
reported back as soon as the information
members asked for has been provided and
assessed
it was assessed as an a1 class oak tree
with excellent potential
by snitterfield sports club's own
aborticulturalist
core strategy cs5 includes that trees
that are of high public immunity will be
removal of trees of high public immunity
will be resisted
and such trees will be protected by the
use of tpos
as per paragraph 131 of the mppf
planning decisions should ensure that
existing trees are retained wherever
possible
oak trees support more life than any
other native tree species in the uk
they're one of the greatest for
potential carbon storage
trees are ultimate carbon capture and
storage machines they reduce pollution
reduce flooding and support wildlife
the council has also declared a climate
emergency
is that the end of your report now thank
you very much
okay so we've heard from the officer
uh we'll move on to our first speaker
please uh councillor claudine pearson
chairman of snooterfield parish council
you'll have
three minutes i'll get you would you
like a 30 second warning to say you're
getting close to the end
uh 30 seconds sounds good yes please
sorry sega yes please okay
fine may i remove my mask just yes thank
you
good evening um before i begin may may i
apologize to members
for not submitting an adequate video of
the tree in time for committee this
evening
if members are familiar with the world
written road they will understand that
the approach is up or down a steep hill
on a road well known for speeding
even driving slowly in late autumn
weather the clip was a blink and you've
missed it
in this way i'd like to draw members
attention to the public view of this
tree
snitterfield's main neighborhood
development plan identifies valued
landscapes on page 39 and the views
discussed here is not one of them
it is a case of the right tree in the
wrong place with only a fleeting glimpse
as you exit the village
snitterfield bearish council has weighed
the balance of preserving the view of
this one tree in the here and now
against the future health and well-being
of snitchfield's residents
centerfield parish council asks members
to consider the consequences of
confirming this order
the size of the housing will be
compromised
the two and three bedroom houses will
have to be reduced in size to
accommodate the tree's future growth
nine households will be living in
smaller accommodation with smaller
gardens
this harms midfield residents
the cost of the development will
increase with specialist surveys and
foundations to accommodate this tree
the scheme may become financially
unviable as a result with less
properties and lower sale prices
this puts the scheme at risk and
potentially leaves residents without a
sports club
this goes against the maid neighborhood
development plan and harms smithfield
residents
if the cost of the development increases
there is a corresponding decrease in
money available for extras
that is to say the bespoke tree planting
scheme put forward by steadfield tree
action group
who intend to plant over 200 native
species of trees and scrub to offset
climate change
this scheme proposes the right trees in
the right place to be enjoyed by
everyone
to forego this tree planting harms
snitchfield residents
and arguably the climate
this scheme forms part of snitterfield's
made neighborhood development plan you
have objections before you from the
sports club the neighborhood development
committee and snitchfield parish council
in any decision there is a cost benefit
analysis and in this instance the cost
of preserving this one single tree
will be born not by a developer but by
snitchfield residents
we hope that members will have 30
seconds that snitchfield residents must
be prioritized over this one tree please
refuse the order
thank you
thank you very much
does anyone have any questions for the
council
council members yes thank you good
evening and and thank you um
are you are you saying that if you keep
this tree the whole
application for the um
for the event will fall apart
right sorry um it is looking
increasingly unviable because it has
been two and a half years in the
meantime there have been at least two
changes in the layout
um currently there are still objections
the planning officer is um
not supportive of the design of the
houses
um
we know that to
uh to accommodate the tree
the housing is being pushed to one size
to accommodate the future growth so
therefore we're talking about nine
houses that are two and three bedroom
that snitchfield wants and needs
are going to be compromised as a result
and we know that that is a bottom line
of profit that the developer may or may
not
but
on the previous applications this didn't
come up today no it didn't come up so
it's as much of a surprise it's only
this one now it's come up because
the uh
design of the next
or layout the next application is
altered it this application came to
committee that the the application for
the development came to committee in
summer
and that was the first we had heard of
this oak tree um as i say to centerfield
residents
it is it is a surprise and it's not
really uh something that they have
valued as you can see from the made
neighborhood development plan that tree
was not identified as important
thank you
thank you very much thank you
if you could uh just give the table a
wipe down and throw the thing in the bin
that would be excellent thank you
next speaker
mr patrick elliott chairman of schnitter
field sports club
mr elliott you have three minutes
hello
okay
yeah yeah yes please you'll have three
minutes would you like a 30 second
warning when we get near these
okay no problem
can i start yeah okay good evening i'm
patrick elliott chairman of
schnitzerville sports club
i've been involved in the running of
this club for the past 14 years
over the past four years we've been
working with ivan holmes who have agreed
to build as a state-of-the-art
energy-efficient sports club building
in return they will acquire the existing
building footprint and part of our car
park to build nine
times at two and three bedroom houses
this planning application has been with
the district planner since january 2020.
this proposed development is in
accordance with their ndp which is
approved by 94 percent of those who
voted
our plans have been shared via leaflet
drop and via snipe newsletter delivered
to all centerfield residents free of
charge as well as a public consultation
on the avon homes planning application
there is no mention of this tree when
our planning application became before
this committee in march 21.
whilst we understand the tpo as a
separate process we had no idea until
this summer that the treaty was
considered to be of such high immunity
value
this tpo was in fact instigated by a
neighbor whose house is approximately 85
metres from the tree that's my estimate
with my dog the sports club building is
eight meters from the tree we fully
understand in these days of climate
change that tree should be taken
protected
but we consider this tpo to be vexatious
rather than a genuine desire to protect
the tree
this tpo has delayed that avon homes
application and potentially could result
in its refusal and the closure of the
club
we have managed to survive through covid
but our building continues to
deteriorate in the past couple of weeks
the club has to spend over three
thousand pounds on repairs to the
building including a new boiler our
planning consultant is of the the
opinion that a tpo should not be made on
this tree when assessed against the
various sort of the relevant legal
requirements as detailed in the town of
country planning act as follows
visibility
the extent to which trees or the
woodlands can be seen by the public we
do acknowledge that the tree can be seen
from the walton road if walking
or driving within the speed limit but
visibility alone is not sufficient to
orbit an order rather the importance of
the tree should be considered
the immunity provided by a tree should
also be considered yes which is visible
from the road but it is not unusual it's
not a rare species we believe it's
self-seeded in the middle of a hedge
close to our existing building with that
in mind we would request that this tpo
is considered in the round
i.e the significant benefits and the
immediacy will be that will be provided
by either the proposed redevelopment of
the system got 30 seconds to deliver a
new clubhouse or if planning is not
granted the threat to the existing club
out of the tree is allowed to grow to
maturity
bear in mind the sports club working
with a specifically triatic group
offered to plant
200 trees and shrubs on our site and and
do maintenance on some of the other
existing trees we consider that this
will have a better immunity benefit in
this one tree the bottom line is that a
new energy efficient building nine
houses and a plan to plant 200 trees and
shrubs are all at risk tpo all we're
trying to do is save sport in the
village
sorry okay
thank you mr elliot uh do you regard
this tree as being on your own on the
sports club's land
because obviously there's some uh
comments within the report as to whether
it's on the boundary or possibly in the
neighbors um i read the rules i thought
i wasn't allowed to talk about boundary
issues
the rules that were sent out to me
just been ruled and not a relevant
question at the time
not relevant that it's uh
potentially not on their land okay thank
you
it's been determined so far uh council
dixon that it may be on the sports
club's land and also on the adjoining
owner's land
at the moment
okay right thank you very much you just
give the table a wipe and
retire
that's right uh next speaker we have uh
board member
councillor richards
i shouldn't take up four or five minutes
share but if i do please give me a money
but i'll give you the warning if you if
you need it
thank you
members
like you i find myself in uncharted
territory tonight
first of all i don't think i've ever
seen a tpo come before this committee
and secondly i don't think i've ever
seen a tpo that's been objected to by
parish council and ward member and the
landowner
the parish council and sports club
representative have outlined their
issues and concerns with this tpo and i
wholeheartedly agree with what they have
said
rather than repeat what has been said
what i want to do is draw your attention
to the timing of the issue of the tpo
and the impact that has had and will
have
as you've heard the sports club have
submitted a planning application for a
modest number of homes and a new sports
pavilion on this site that application
is supported by me the parish council
and is identified as a site in our
neighborhood plan many of you i'm sure
will remember deferring that application
in the summer for a site visit and
further information on a various points
throughout that application process
there has been no mention of this tree
or indeed a need for a tpo to
to be forthcoming on this tree or any
other tree
um it's only since the committee meeting
and potentially the perceived direction
of travel from the members debate that
this tpl has suddenly come forward
why now i hear you ask
i have a view
vexatious is a good word but i will
leave you to come to your own
conclusions
for me this is a rather premature
application of a tpo
we know that sports club application
that was deferred in the summer will be
coming to this committee early in the
new year complete with site visit and
all other information that you require
to make your decision on it
the application is set to remove this
tree and plant in its place an
additional 200 replacements
now i recognize we're not here to debate
the merits of that sportshub application
nor would i want you to or expect you to
but it is very relevant when considering
this tpa
so
if you're wanting to grant the tpa today
the sports application sports club
application would need to then evidence
the need to remove that tree that
evidence would of course be forthcoming
as we've heard through structural
engineering reports demonstrating its
impact on the existing sports club
building and and and
i can't even say this
i'll let you guys you know what i mean
uh report to remove them um if the
sports club is granted
the tree would be removed
so potentially this tpo would only be in
place for a month maybe two
alternatively you could defer your
decision tonight and during the site
visit for the sports club you could see
the the tree for yourselves during that
site visit this order could then be
brought back to the committee on the
same day as the sports club application
is heard and if the sports club
application isn't granted by all means
grant this tpa
or and this is my preference to keep
things a little bit tidy you could defer
sorry you could decide to refuse the
orders today and should the sports club
application not be successful in the new
year a new order could be placed on the
tree then after the decision has been
had had its opportunity to be heard
unencumbered
members i will leave you and i trust in
you to make the right decision tonight
given all the facts that have been
presented to you this evening
thank you
thank you counselor rich does anybody
have any questions for the council
council dixon
peter um you just mentioned that there's
a possibility that we could actually as
it were
like defer the situation uh and if it
was a situation whereby in two months
time or whenever the next
hearing is before us we could if it
fell we could then put on the tpo
if however
um
what it what would be wrong with the
provisional if a provisional could be
removed at the same time
as
a new application comes in
the to my understanding what's before us
tonight is only a provisional one not
going to be a permanent one
i wasn't going to answer that [ __ ] i
was going to say the same thing
um
scripture from the prison confirmation
of retreat preservation order so as i
understand it there's already a
provisional
um if
you're making a decision on a permanent
one now
um so and your officers i'm sure will uh
confirm that they're nodding so this is
what you're confirming tonight if you
grant it is there permanent
um this is to take it from provisional
to permanent so the point it becomes
permanent that suddenly creates a
headache for
an application that was deferred in the
summer when this didn't even exist it's
only since that's happened since we
deferred and the direction of travel was
what it was
that we've ended up having a tpo place
that's all our speakers now for for that
so we'll uh move to uh officers
clarifications anybody have any
questions
okay uh councillor mills um
allison
um
i get this right this
we're putting a um
well after you're putting it you want a
tpo on this tree but should i
i'm richard might be on able to answer
this
should the application be put in
to redevelop the sports um
sports club um
again ask would that be a showstopper
no no asking richard sorry really i
suppose um
it remains to be seen what weight that
would hold in the balance of a future
planning application to come before this
committee
it will be a factor but the purpose of
confirming the tpo tonight is so that it
at least remains a factor in that
decision
and and it's protecting its safeguarding
the situation so that all factors can be
balanced in that planning decision
i wouldn't say it would necessarily be a
show stopper
but at least it can still be considered
as part of the redevelopment of the site
one way or another and if we
if we
were to defer this until the application
came in in the meantime they could chop
it down there is a risk that that could
happen yes
right thank you
thank you
yes it's really just to
clarify in my own mind i think
councilman mills
pretty much did this but
this whatever decision we make tonight
if we decide to
extend the tpo and follow the officer's
guidance
a future planning committee
will not be absolutely bound
by that decision the future planning
committee would have the means
to remove that tpo if it were minded to
grant permission to develop
yes it's legitimate to grant a planning
application which involves the removal
of a tpo it just becomes part of the
assessment of that application in ways
in the balance with all other planning
factors
so that future committee would not be
bound
by this in perpetuity as it were that's
correct yes thank you very much that's
very helpful
thank you uh cash addiction who is next
thank you chairman
i take it it's not legally possible to
simply extend the provisional protection
on this tree
no it isn't this is the time that it has
to be made permanently you can't extend
beyond six months
catagenics thank you
so
i just want to get a bit of
clarification on here um
i'll speak loudly then
um would the sports club um on their
application
need to provide evidence to remove the
trees
um should we grant a tpo on it
um i wouldn't
not necessarily evidence they would need
to show
i've got to be careful not to stray into
the pros and cons of a future
application
but obviously if there's a tree on site
and you propose to remove it there's
going to have to be some outweighing
benefits somewhere down the line
and i wouldn't say that that's
impossible by any stretch of the
imagination it just means they've got
it's got to weigh in that balance
yeah evidence planning factors that
weigh in favor of granting it and
outweigh the loss of the tree
a tpo can be revoked
so if
if
if the planning application was granted
and there are certain circumstances that
whereby you now think the tp of the tree
is gone
it doesn't fit a layout it's
inappropriate there can be various
reasons why you would then revoke a tpo
and there's a just a process there's a
process for that
so it can
it can change
but not if the local authority felt it
was appropriate to revoke it because
circumstances have changed
that the term evidence could be very
broad ranging could be a whole number as
you're aware there's many planning
different considerations and there's any
number of those that would be so
beneficial that they outweigh the loss
of a tree or being a valued tree and
that's what could happen as part of a
planning decision in the future
but i do emphasize the word could that
decision hasn't been taken yet
kesha curtis yes sorry
sorry thanks joe i'm still down here
alison
councillor richards
mentioned the um
the fact that this tree
that the tpo or the tree wasn't
considered in the previous application
can you sort of shed any light on why it
wasn't an issue previously
firstly i'm not a planning officer
so i didn't determine or bring that last
item to committee
however
my understanding was
it had been identified by the sports
club's owner boro culturalist as an a1
oak tree it's the highest category you
can get
and that
was then flagged up as a concern
i think once it was deferred from
committee there was it was officers who
were at that meeting felt that this tree
could be under threat
i was then asked to consider whether a
tree preservation order was appropriate
entirely on its own merits in terms of
its amenity its quality its long-term
potential its health its form
and i agreed with sports club's owner
boriculturalist that this was an a1
class oak tree
and a tree preservation order was then
served
uh cancer hence the ceremony
yeah um as it's on the boundary wouldn't
there be a bit of a conflict who owns
history
um the tpo has been served on both uh
possible owners so that point is covered
by the legalities behind the tpo yeah so
but you've got
one resident who wants the tree to
remain
uh as i understand it yes yeah okay
thank you
any other questions for the officers
no
in that case it's uh we'll move to
debate then please anybody want to kick
off a debate
um go with counselor jennings
okay well i'm really uncomfortable with
this one
um
normally i'd i've been very much in
favor of uh of tpos but on this one
it seems to be that
it wasn't considered an issue before um
and i remember when we were on the
being on the committee when we deferred
this one
and to suddenly add in an extra
potential
um
boundary to this
makes me i say it makes me very
uncomfortable um
when you put a tpo on it you have to
then have to provide evidence to remove
the tpo it's not just a simple process
of well we're going to we're going to
all that's just another piece of
evidence which is against
the actual sports
club so i'm really really uncomfortable
at the moment with this
the members back into the
base of the guidance is basically about
the immunity
and also the visibility etc
so
although
this is um this has an impact on the
sports club basically you must look at
the guidance
uh about actually a tree preservation
order about confirming it i can put the
the wording on the actual screen for you
so you can have a look
but that's what we have to assess on the
tree preservation order
i can do that
didn't really want to see that
yeah send this
if i get the right one
let's look at the right one
hello again
can i make that bigger or not
and i must make the point actually the
centerfield the chairman of the field
sports club also brought up on his age
and actually brought up the rules as
well with regard to
the rules uh when you actually uh are
looking at confirming a tree
preservation order
the counselors can tell me when they
want to move on because that's just the
first part what does amelity mean in
practice
and then what might a local authority
take into account when assessing
immunity value
the visibility individual collective and
wider impact and other factors
that's what they should that's what the
council should be assessing
so
where would you like me to
carry on with that would like to make
the point now i'd like to make the point
okay thank you very much um caso
jennings was saying that in order to
remove it in the future we need evidence
um i think not everything
that i think justification which i think
might be a slightly different aspect
because in the future when we do
as we will i'm sure be doing at some
time assessing an application for the
sports ground
um in the balance of that decision
making we can consider whether or not
to continue preserving the tree or
whether in the balance
of provision of affordable homes three
bedroom homes two bedroom homes whatever
is on that application
if we actually concern that they
counter balance and over balance the
protection of a tree
we would be in a position thereby
nothing to justify the removal of a tpo
so essentially i am minded at this stage
to protect that tree
and i would support the officer
recommendation in that regard thank you
thank you casa dixon uh casamill
thanks richard um yeah this is
an a1
grade
oak tree yes
um
yeah as council james i'm uncomfortable
with this one um
and i think i have agree with them
council dixon there
i said we alluded well i tried to loot
earlier that if
an application came in
and we had a tpo on this it wouldn't be
a showstopper would it so
at the moment i will be in favor of uh
going with the obvious recommendation
thank you is that a second or yeah i can
second did you propose it
okay
i'll propose it then
and i'll second each other okay
thank you thank you chad um
like many others and content around the
room i feel
really
uncomfortable about any decision on this
um
i think it's it's quite interesting i
think we have to
or should i believe give due weight to
the views of the parish council and
their plan
and
94 of those who voted voted in favor
of the neighborhood plan
and i think it's quite
reassuring in a way
to find
so often parish councils object to new
developments
in the neighborhood i think it's quite
reassuring
that in this particular instance the
parish council
is clearly in favor of a new development
and the fact that it will enable them to
have this fantastic sports facility
which
you know villages really really do need
i just i suppose my my
question is
would this
temporary
or
would this imposition of the tpo
um
really damage the prospects of
the club going forward if permission
were delayed or if permission were then
granted in february march when
everything's going to come back
i'm
i find this a very very because
as it's been said
the idea of felling a beautiful tree
is really
is uh not something i want to support
okay
can you hence
did you wish to speak
yes um
i think we should go
with after the recommendation as it is
now and
wait to see what application comes
forward
i'm sure they can adjust
um
maybe losing one house on this
development to protect this tree
because it is an a1 oak tree
thank you
okay um just to give my sort of two
pennies in this really um
we we've heard that um the planning
application can override the tpo
um
but i think in the meantime i think in
the short term we should be protecting
the tree just to make sure it doesn't
disappear before the planet application
arrives and i think that's the important
thing that we
extend by whatever means we can
the existing the existing preservation
order
so i'll be supporting councillor mills
and councillor dixon with uh with my
application with my vote
are there any other any other people
want to speak on debate
no so we should move to a vote then
shall we
um can we we've got a proposal um to uh
go along with the officer's
recommendations we've had proposal and
second
modification on the type of chair
because sorry again the wrong
we've noticed that there's a typo in
here so we agree with that that change
um
so
can we have we've got a proposal we've
got a second
to agree with the officer's
recommendation to maintain the tree
preservation order
until we see such times we see a plan
application come in
so can we have a vote then
for those in favor of the proposal
five
sorry
we've got an abstention at the far end
we have an obsession test
okay fine so with that vote in mind
we agreed to go with the
officers recommendations to maintain the
gpa
thank you very much
members ladies and gentlemen we are just
going to have a two-minute recess and
we're having as you can tell we're
having technical issues so we're just
going to try and resolve those and we'll
be back in just a moment so if you want
to grab a drink from outside or use the
loop please do
aldi
before we go live again can i just check
that we do have all our speakers for the
bedford item
thank you
okay ladies and gents we are back now
and we will be going live i think we've
resolved our issues if we have any more
microphone issues i think we have a way
to deal with it so if you have issues
let us know oh i'm sure you will anyway
um okay so our next item uh is
application twenty one zero two zero one
one f u l eleven to thirteen white gates
uh welford road barton uh members i
believe we might have forgotten um a
disclosure um i've just been reminded of
this we had an email earlier in the week
with some slides on
um so i think you're all looking at me
blankly i know we did because i've just
seen it again and so if you could all
agree that we've seen it we're all here
with an open mind
good okay marvelous um
let's move on so
alison where's alison don over to you
whenever you're ready thank you mr
chairman
so
this application is for
single-story extensions to the front and
rear of an existing dwelling and the
erection of a detached garage and store
the general location is shown by the
black dot
this is the application site shown by
the red line
it sits within barton conservation area
is identified as being of individual
local interest and local group value in
the barton conservation area report
and in close proximity to a number of
listed buildings
so
letterbox cottage
here
the cottage of content pub being the
closest
both grade two listed
here is an aerial view of the site
showing the approximate application site
outlined in red
so the cottage of content pub is here
the car park pub car park
campsite to the rear
so the pub and the letterbox cottage are
both listed as i said
there is a public right-of-way starting
at the corner
here
which runs north
so this this slide shows the before and
after elevations
the house the original house which was
two originally two separate cottages
is a typical example of local vernacular
being simple and traditional in design
it dates from the late victorian period
and is mainly built from red brick
painted white with areas of older stone
work
the roof is plain pitched slate
so single story extensions are proposed
on both the north and south elevations
so here
and here
and the extent
of the extensions are shown in the inset
shaded orange
so
here
and here
so this slide shows the extent of the
proposed north and south extensions that
will largely obscure the original
elevations of the house
you can also see the cutouts in the
pitched roof of the proposed extensions
like this bits here
and here
they're known as inverted dormers
and they're in front of
most of the first existing first four
windows
so moving on to the new garage store
which also has accommodation above
that's to be located to the southeast of
the house
in this area
the proposed height of the new garage
building is 5.35 meters
and the height of the eastern half of
the dwelling is 5.8 meters
the house
will still have three bedrooms after
renovation
so part o of development requirements
spd requires two parking spaces for
three-bedroom house
the proposal includes the provision of
two parking spaces in the proposed
garage
here
which will replace the existing off-road
parking
available
currently within the site
this area is shared driveway
however the dimensions of the proposed
garage
the parking spaces fall short of the
minimum required length and crucially
width to qualify as car parking spaces
as set out in part o of the spd
so this slide shows the north and south
elevations of the house
this application the the application
uh
site is in the center of this picture
behind this tree you can just see it
just about
so
finally the last few shot
last few slides show a number of the
surrounding listed buildings and barton
conservation area
so this is the side elevation of the
hub
this is
letterbox house with the cottage of
content pub next door the application
site is to the rear
and this slide shows little cottage with
the shared access to the side
mr chairman that's the end of my
presentation
there are um
some updates on the update sheet and the
recommendation is therefore that the
application be refused for the three
reasons detailed in the report thank
you alison thank you very much indeed
and let's invite our first speaker
councillor penny taylor would you like
to make your way forward
i don't know
we will just check and see if we can
pull them up yeah
cancer tell you you may you may not have
been aware we can't we're not supposed
to accept uh slides with writing on so
we've had to remove a lot of it there's
still a little bit on there and we're
going to make exception for this because
we didn't tell you in time but uh just
so you're away they may not look the
same as when you send them to us
um okay so you have three minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning otherwise
whenever you're ready please feel free
to start
right thank you well first of all i just
wanted to say i was genuinely um
grateful to catherine givens with such a
detailed report because it's important
that we take care of conservation areas
like barton so thank you for that
um white gates has been derelict for
many years covered in creeper overgrown
trees and shrubs you couldn't see the
house at all from any angle it's just
been completely covered
um i'll be focusing on the house because
of time constraints and i know the
applicant will be mentioning the garage
because that's important too
on design and distinctiveness first of
all a reminder that white gates is not a
listed building um the applicant is
requesting two small single story
extensions as you've seen
whether or not the plans are a good
design can be subjective i think that we
think of the pressure council that
they're practical and um imaginative
and into that we've got now at least 21
strongly supportive comments sent in
from 19 households in barton so that's
about
half the village households of the
permanent permanent houses there there'd
be no comments against
um
uh in the core strategy cs20 encourages
modifications that enable homeowners to
realize the potential of the property
and improve the quality of their lives
and it adds the council supports such
aspirations
it also says that renovating existing
dwellings is often a more sustainable
and environmentally friendly approach
than replacing existing dwellings in
their entirety
so i think that applies to white gates
um if we look at the slides the first
one shows what is visible of white white
gates from the road and you can just see
to the left of left box cottage that a
wall that will not be changed it happens
to have scaffolding on the top at the
moment because roofing work is repairs
are going on
um
next slide um
i think the slides might said that that
view you've seen you can you can't
actually see the house from that from
that view just the out building
um the next one
the view from the pub car park as we've
seen before that's the only extension
that will be seen by anybody and that
will be that one from the car park and
the next slide there's some examples of
other village houses as a bungalow
and the house on the right which is hard
for you to see is a stone and glass very
modern house that's been built on the
top of the hill and that was from
planning permission in 2015. so there is
variety in the village it's a village a
living village
on residential immunity the report
accepts that the proposal would not
unacceptably detract from the amenities
of neighbouring properties by way of
overlooking overbearing and
overshadowing impact 30 seconds so it
sorry 30 seconds 30 seconds so i better
speed up then it seems um
so i'll talk about better talk a bit
about the history because um
the report says that the level of harm
to the heritage asset will be placed at
less than substantial but that's a
public benefit argument hasn't been
presented um i would say that given that
it's brought it up to the 21st century
um and it's it's a viable home with a
home office proposed above the garage
that that fulfills the requirement of it
and that's why the parish council
strongly supports this planning
application
that's spot on thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our parish council
please go ahead
car park yes um
there's been a question there about the
width of being able to get two cars in
there could you elaborate on that um
it's a car port and i think it'd
probably be better for the applicant to
talk about that because he's
much more knowledgeable about the sizes
and cars and i think another but it's a
three-bedroom house it had three spaces
the plan is three spaces
um
as far as i know but i think you should
ask the applicant
any other questions members
no in that case counselor thank you very
much for your contribution thank you if
you could give the desk a quick wipe
down while we call forward our next
speaker who is mr paul tallants
please do come forward if you want to
grab a seat at the table to my left
you're right that'll be perfect
thank you
so in the similar way you have three
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning whenever you're ready if you
press the button in the middle feel free
to start
okay i should get straight on to this
um white gates retains many of its
internal features uh stone floors open
fireplaces open
stone walls unfortunately
many of the external features have
disappeared over time and we're left
with
brickwork of varying sizes painted white
the west elevation is totally rendered
um of the 13 existing windows no three
windows are the same some are wood some
are metal
some are wood and metal some have six
pane casements some are three some have
one
all around the storage state repair
these will be dealt with a subsequent
planning application white gates is set
back from the main road and mainly
hidden from view by letterbox cottage
the only time you see white gates is
when entering the lane leading to mobile
home site
um
and the entrance leading to cottage
contents car park the proposed single
story extensions to the north is again
not visible from the road part of the
proposed extension is to replace part of
white gates that is not fit for purpose
being constructed of single skinned
brickwork and asbestos tiled roof this
once contained the kitchen this part of
the proposed extension is only slightly
larger than the existing and would have
little or no impact on the surrounding
area or properties most of the extension
would be hidden from view by the
renovated victorian oven health and
washroom yeah
building shown on plants
the proposed new kitchen area is visible
only from the bubble would eliminate
subsidence issue to this part of the
white gates
the proposed single-story extension to
the south elevation is not visible
from the main road or surrounding
properties and would have little or no
impact on surrounding area or properties
it too would also eliminate subsidence
issue with this part of white gates
materials to be used will match existing
i.e painted brickwork slaters the post
double garage to
to replace the two existing single
timber built garages
is
smaller in dimensions and stratford
planners specified but is still
able to comfortably accommodate two
vehicles with a parking space in front
of for one further vehicle the pitch of
the roof can be reduced
to match that white gates and would
render the loft space for storage and a
small office only the external staircase
shows
shown on the proposed plans can be
replaced with stairs to the inside the
garden store to access this area light
gates is a three-bedroom dwelling and
all remains that the proposed parking
spaces are the same as existing i
believe i believe the proposed modest
extensions would bring white gates in
the 21st century while still retaining
much of its 18th century character and
charm i do not agree with the planners
planning officers concerned that
development would detract and spoil the
surrounding area
also the impact on the listed buildings
in the hamlet of barton if this planning
application is passed by the committee
then conditions attached would be
followed accordingly thank you
perfect thank you very much
i was trying to slot into 30 seconds but
you were talking so quickly i couldn't
find a gap
okay members do we have any questions
that's regenexx
car parking um how many cars can you get
in there at the moment the garage widths
can you make sure your microphone's on
sorry
the garage widths are correct i believe
it's the depth of the garage which
doesn't allow a bicycle to be parked
behind the car
which is part of the
planning
well
perhaps three
yeah
cassie jennings remember to turn your
microphone on we do need everyone to
hear it
you have any further questions
thank you chairman mr talent you
mentioned there i think that uh the
staircase for the garage could be turned
in
into the inside the
the garage carport as such and that the
ridge height could be reduced
have you actually submitted any drawings
or amendments for the planners to assess
with those amendments on at all
thank you
kim has any other questions
sorry councillor curses thank you
[Music]
thank you very much
you mentioned the mobile home site
adjacent to can you just click is it a
is it static mobile homes or a touring
caravans mobile homes it's um not the
cottage of contents campsite it it's
further down the lane so it's a mobile
home yeah i was just using it as a
reference yeah no it's just gives it a
little bit more context thank you very
much
okay unless there are any other
questions which i don't think there are
no mr talents thank you very much for
your contribution if you could give the
desk a quick wipe good man on it already
okay our next and final speak on this
item is counselor pemberton councillor
pemsen if you want to make your way
forward please
you know the drill you've got five
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
use as much or as little as the five
minutes as you wish
and whenever you're comfortable and
seated you may start
i hope that's not your speech
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee for hearing my uh
representation in relation to this
application
along with the parish council i'd like
to thank the officer for a full and
detailed report
um unfortunately i along with the parish
council and um now
20 or more residents of barton
for a hamlet that has something like 40
homes so circa 50 percent of the
residents the parish council the ward
member the owner of the grade two listed
building cottage content adjacent to
the application site property
all firmly and resoundingly support
granting planning permission in this
particular case this is the second
unique application after a tpo
you have a conservation area and you
have a parish council board member and
residents fully in support of an
application
members
the applicant has already explained to
you that certainly from the externals
that which made
the benefit of this property much of
which
has eroded
the property can be described as
described in the report as in a state of
disrepair dilapidated is the word i
would use this is a well-known property
it is adjacent to the cottage of content
um to help members uh there is a touring
uh
caravan pitch
at the back of the pub used in the
summer the other side of the pub there
is a 10 month of the year round static
caravan park
so members
this is a property that needs to be
brought back into use brought back to
become
an asset
the purpose of uh
conservation areas is to conserve and
protect it is difficult to argue that
conserving and protecting uh is the
continuation of a dilapidated property
um may i just ask if the uh slides from
penny taylor be brought back up uh they
were the the applicants if it perhaps
just take us pause while we do that
chair thank you
bring those up on share screen
um if
uh if you just go back a slider um so
you the first two you've got uh
traditional properties next slide
on to the next slide after the cutting
consent
please the next slide
beyond that to the three with properties
so you've got
that's a demonstration of an eclectic
mix of properties 70s 50s
within barton um and you should see to
be the third i think um
that is an under construction 21st
century concrete and glass flat
uh uber home
which is has the most prominent position
in barton on the top of the hill it's a
fabulous construction
it is a demonstration that conservation
areas can live in conjunction with many
other types of construction
whilst i would not go so far as to say
that the application site and design
which while interesting and a reasonable
attempt to
reinvigorate the property are of that
class it does demonstrate there are
other the rather of the
opportunities to solve the problem
officers uh it is only the officer who
is concerned about this and even the
officer refers to a less than
substantial harm
policies
both at the neighborhood development and
core strategy level again talk about how
we would approach less substantial harm
which is to identify the public benefit
the officer believes that the benefit is
solely economic uh to the applicant
alone i would strongly disagree with
that statement in the sense of the
bringing back into use of this building
to create an asset to create a living
building
of itself adds public realm benefit by
an improvement of the building by a
building that's being used by a building
that adds to the life and vitality of
the hamlet of barton so i think it is
within the decision makers gift to take
an alternate view from that outlined by
officers in weighing the balance of harm
that there is harm um cannot be disputed
but it is all agreed to be less than
substantial and members can weigh in the
balance the other benefits of bringing
the building back into use and i would
strongly urge members to in this
instance unfortunately go against
officers recommendations and grant
planning permission thank you i will
take any questions you have
30 seconds
well done well done members do we have
any questions for casa dixon
uh just the one um the old orchard which
you sort of
made mention of as being a grand design
on top of the hill how close is that to
the conservation area or is it in it
it's in the conservation area
any other questions members
have some mills
on your um presentation here you
mentioned there is harm what what harm
was that
you said you said there is harm well
i i think i
the officer has set that set out that
the the the the design and by nature of
the extension of the building
does create harm in the
conservation area that harm is less than
substantial in essence the sort of
pretty much the lowest level of harm you
can have within a conservation area and
still make some form of development and
in those circumstances as decision
makers you weigh up the harm versus the
public benefit of the development and i
think the strong contention of the
applicant the parish council myself as
wood member and 50 percent of the
residents of barton is that the the
benefits outweigh the harm and therefore
members are entitled to take an
alternate view to offices
thank you council of pemberton
any other questions for council of
hermeson
no in that case council pempton thank
you very much for your contribution if
you could kindly mop the desk once
you've closed up all those files and
folders would be appreciated
okay let's move to questions of our
offices members do we have any points of
clarification council mills first thank
you very much chairman um alison um
the can you tell me what the height of
the um
the gallery is compared with the house
itself please
so the height of the new garage is 5.35
meters
and the height of the eastern half of
the existing dwelling is 5.8 meters
my point i said this
yeah yeah
thank you thank you very much um so um
can you
show me on the
where's the garage that's it
so that that's the that's the garage
there
that's the house there's the garage
so yeah
while you're on that slide can you zoom
in onto the garage so we can see those
red lines a bit more clearly please
so um so if you've got any more
questions customers before i come in
john faraway yeah and also on the on
that garage
there's a question on the depth of the
garage but you can get a car in there
it's like you know it's more like a car
port isn't it
[Music]
so
this is the drive the cars would come in
and
drive into the carport this way if you
can just see underneath the red lines
there's one bay here another bay here
and this end is the
story so the so for clarity the red
lines indicate the minimum standard that
we require through our spd
and judging from that they overlap the
store side by side and also are
too long
for the garage is that correct
um
forgive me for hijacking you slightly
here customers um so presumably
your refusal number three which is
insufficient parking relates to the fact
that that those cannot be used as
parking spaces and there isn't anywhere
else to put three cars is that correct
that's two there's a three-bedroom town
so there's two requirements for two
parking spaces
so currently cars park
in that space
so if that building was built there's
nowhere else to park because the area to
the south is share driveway but if the
cars fitted in there we wouldn't have
that as a reason for refusal because
that would be okay
okay so it's the size of it basically so
so
can the cars fit in there or not
i think i think the i think the answer
is that
possibly um a small car might but those
are the minimum standards required for
rspd and when put side by side on that
building
clearly we can see that it's too long
and
goes into the store so i think that's
the position that officers are trying to
or are taking
counselor jennings
so
what i'd like to get is a bit more
clarification on what is a shared
boundary so a shared driveway or what is
because a car doesn't necessarily if it
is carport it can stick out to the end
and whether the front of the car
is on if as long as it's on its own
property it doesn't matter surely
and can you put one car in
like that then one car
in front of it that way
so i'm just trying to ascertain exactly
what is owned the what part of the
driveway is owned
by the by the owners
and what is shared
i think you've got a dotted line there
so if you could get a car
in
to the main car park at bay on the left
but you know it sticks out a little bit
could you then put a car in front of it
yeah it has crossed office's minds that
you if you overhang the back by a few
centimeters that wouldn't be so much a
problem but that's not the only issue
with it it's not wide enough according
to the spd and that that is is much more
important because it's just too narrow
to fit most cars in there um it's
possible to put some smaller cars in
there but the spd is designed to cater
for a variety of vehicles
okay okay
do you have a further follow-up
and we can come back to you if you want
i'll come back to it cancer curtis
please uh thank you um
alison you mentioned that the
this development is in close proximity
to listed buildings
and can you give us the age of those
other listed buildings
roughly
i don't think we we can answer that
specifically we could house it again i
suspect that the parish should probably
be um
more in the know on that but there's
certainly more than 150 to them so
perhaps
so
well well pre-victorian
i would say so yes yeah that was what i
thought thank you
cass jennings coming back to you
is it possible to put some sort of
condition on there because obviously
it's to me it's the technicality on the
width there where they've done the
drawings if they're just added a little
bit more then obviously be able to get a
car in there easily and you could
possibly put one in front
you could remove the stove
let's not try and change the application
on the hoof the reality is it doesn't
fit the spd which is why that's a reason
for refusal also have a look at reason
for food number two which is the
proposed siting size and scale and so
you need to overcome that as well if
you're extending that then that
increases the impact of reason number
two just bear that in mind
okay
any other questions for officers
new
let's open up the debate who would like
to kick us off councillor dixon
uh we heard from the applicant that uh
it would be
possible to potentially put the
staircase in respect to the garage
inside
and also to reduce the ridge height of
the garage
certainly we have a parking issue so i
would actually support the officer's
recommendation but suggest that the
applicant
makes some amendments to the application
and comes back
is that proposal
i'm happy to propose that the officer's
recommendation yes thank you very much
councillor curtis please
thank you um just a few thoughts really
um the reason i was asking about the age
of the
the listed buildings is that you know
clearly when this
house was originally built
um victorian um it was
in close proximity to that that was in
close proximity listed buildings it was
a modern house at the time it was built
compared to the existing properties
there
um
and i although it mentions that
um it is in close proximity from what
we've seen
i think the visibility
of this development is pretty minimal
from these listed buildings and i
i think picking up council mills comment
earlier um i'm i'm really sort of trying
to see
what demonstrable
harm
this development would actually have
so thank you
councilmelson
thanks mr chairman yeah i'm as you know
always going to these
applications and
it is in a terrible state um
and i thought well it can't be seen
absolutely right but i have to say this
garage size does just concern me and
that's what we're looking at isn't it um
i'm
i'm almost inclined to go along with uh
council dixon there almost almost
let me help you decide shall i go
um i am going to second cancer dixon's
proposal yeah and let me give some meat
to the bones as to why i'm doing that
whilst i to a large degree um agree with
what council curses have said about the
the property itself and yes it you know
in its day it was modern for its time we
should be bringing it back into use and
um whilst i don't necess and this is a
personal view don't necessarily like the
style of the windows and what have you
that's a personal view that's subjective
um
i can see why others might like it and
in my mind what outweighs the harm from
that style is the fact that we're
bringing in back into use a perfectly
reasonable building we should be doing
that where i do have a problem is with
the garage and it is unfortunate and i
think as council dixon has said if if
this were to come
if this would come in slightly smaller
slightly shorter
with sufficient space to be able to
plant two cars i don't think we'd have
in this conversation but the reality is
it doesn't fit with rspd so therefore
two cars cannot fit
in that so it's against our policy we
have to have very good reason to go
against that policy and i don't think we
have which certainly hasn't been put
forward to us so far so that's why
reluctantly i am
uh going to be going with the officer's
recommendations
i may ask you and i can ask this mr
chairman so if the applicant would come
back with a separate application and
that would suit our not suitable uh
which would be if you're gonna ask me
which way i'd vote on that let's wait
until it comes in because i ain't
predetermined
that is true yes forget that
would anyone else like to contribute
towards the base at this point council
jennings
i can get this
the
i don't have a problem with the design
here at all i think it's absolutely
great i like the inverted dormers
everything about it i like i don't i
don't think there's a substantial damage
um
i think it is the public benefit
certainly bring house back into use
certain counterbalances
um even with the size of the garage i
don't have a problem with that either um
i'm just a bit gutted about the
technicality on the
on the on the garage space um
it's a real shame that that wasn't
brought to light or amended at some
point earlier
i think it is a shame but it is what it
is
if anyone else likes to contribute at
this point if not we'll move to a vote
okay in that case the proposal uh
council dixon uh and myself for second
year and put forward to go along with
the officer's recommendation and refused
planning permission for the reasons
given could i please have a show of
hands for those in favor
and those against
and
abstentions and committee therefore
resolves to refuse application twenty
one zero two zero one one full for the
reasons given thank you very much
members okay we'll move swiftly on to
our next item which is application
reference twenty one zero one 9 8 8 f u
l that's 24 even crescent stratfor
uneven our presenting officer is once
again alison willis allison over to you
oh actually before you do let's cancel
fleming get back council
fleming if you wouldn't mind thank you
jeremy to try this
okay uh alison whenever you're ready
over to you
thank you mr chairman
so
this is an application for two-story
side extension to an existing
semi-detached property only in present
with a single story rear extension
it includes the demolition of an
existing single-story side extension
and a rear door window to
the existing attic room general location
was shown by the black dot
this is the application type site shown
by the red line
it's on even present the site is not
within a conservation area
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
you can see the eastern boundary
the side elevation of a house under
consideration which is painted white
this is where the proposed extension
would be
although the house houses are of similar
age and use a similar pallet of
materials there is still a variety of
building heights boundary treatments
front drives gardens window styles and
extension forms
there is a very general curve to the
road but this is a very weak building
line as there are numerous examples of
where the buildings are in front or are
behind
it's by no means uniform
so
this slide shows the initial proposals
that were submitted
following officer advice the design of
the submitted scheme was amended during
the course of the application
the pitched roof at the front
here
was replaced with a hipped roof and the
bay windows here and here
on the front elevation were omitted
[Music]
so this slide shows the footprint of the
amended proposed extension
which is in line with the existing front
elevation
here and
here
please note that the existing front
elevation of number 24
the application site is already forwards
of the neighboring house number 26
number 26 here
the extension extends to the east but
retains the existing side access
down here
so this slide shows the proposed front
rear and side elevations
the extension now has a hitch roof here
and there are no new bay windows on the
front elevation
on the side elevation
you note there are
side facing windows
on the ground floor
to the utility room kitchen
two roof lights to give light to the
bedroom and the ensuite rather than
additional side facing windows
and a lantern over the kitchen
so
these few pictures of the front
front side
and rear elevations
and a view
here of where the rear extension would
be sited
as well as the side of number 26 next
door
so
there was a committee site visit this
afternoon
but in addition to that i have actually
taken a video of the street scene
which i think illustrates
the situation if you just bear with me
while i find it
so this is taken from
the front dashboard of my car and i'm
just about to turn to the left
into even present
so that if you can see there that's
number 24 there okay
you just keep that in mind
i think that's given you another label
of the variety i think so i'll just
pause it there
um so that's the end of my presentation
mr chairman there are a few updates on
the update sheet
um as i mentioned there was a committee
site visit this afternoon
the recommendation is therefore
that the application be granted subject
to the conditions and notes contained in
the agenda the detailed world wedding
number of which is granted to officers
allison thank you very much indeed let's
invite our first speaker who is mrs
hannah madden
please if you'd like to make your way
forward grab a seat
good evening uh you will have three
minutes i'll give you 30 seconds before
your time is up otherwise whenever
you're ready to start if you press the
button in the middle of the microphone
it will go red and feel free to start
um i currently reside at number 26 even
crescent and
my feeling is the two-story extension
will be in line with the frontage number
24 but will stand considerably proud of
number 26 causing some distortion
aesthetics of the crescent itself and
also the element of outside looking
outside of my house as well from
both downstairs windows so the potential
is i'll see quite a lot of brick wall
um there instead of being able to look
down the crescent
um i also feel this adversely impacts
the value on my property
in 2006 my late husband and i actually
put in a similar planning submission and
it was refused on the grounds if number
24
undertook a two-story it would cause a
terrorist effect
i'm assuming that his presidency has
been set on what grounds has it do to be
reversed
um and obviously if i was able to sell
that property i can't afford to do a
tour story now um
you know if someone else put planning in
for number 26 or a two-story would that
get refused and again what's the
president's on that if this one gets
approved
um
i'm also talking on behalf of number 22
which is the international property
unfortunately they're unable to come
because they're poorly i have no
say on their objections so i'm not to
answer any questions i'm literally just
saying what they want me to say um they
were concerned about the flat roof
extension at the rear which is sideways
onto theirs about 10 feet from their
lounge apparently
lighting and lack of privacy also they
were concerned about the dormer window
and the roof of concerns about privacy
and just felt that the project is too
big for the size of the plot
that was it really
obvious well within your time thank you
very much members do we have any
questions for ms madden before she
departs
no
looks like you covered all bases so
thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay we will call forward our next
speaker who is mrs jane hughes the agent
and miss marianne mcleod our applicant
if you'd like to make your way forward
feel free to take a desk each if you
like
now you've got three minutes between the
two of you who's going to be doing the
speaking are you going to be using all
three minutes
so i'll give you a 30 second warning
you're presumably here for questions
perfect okay so you know the drill 30
second warning will come but otherwise
three minutes whenever you're ready over
to you
um good evening the president has been
set for a diversity of extensions
on this part of avon crescent
householders have realized their desire
to build and extend and the wealth of
styles and sizes exist
different widths depth fronts to back
single and double height all in close
quarters of the applicant site
these extensions all satisfy the
planning process and the need to be
subservient to the original property
making a distinction between old
property and new additions as does this
proposal which is supported by the
officers the committee members will have
noticed the diversity in this area on
their site visit this afternoon
changes to original houses reflect
social change in reality nobody likes
change this fact is borne out by the
objections received
within the nppf there is flexibility for
design this can be subjected design is
open to interpretation
but all schemes must adhere to current
statutory planning law
and stratfor call strategies
as described by the officer this
proposal upholds the necessary
requirements rig is rigorously tested by
the case officer who we are pleased to
note is recommending this application
under discussion this evening for
approval
the applicant has worked in a positive
and proactive manner with the planning
officer whose hard work and
professionalism we appreciate
the initial proposal received adverse
comments action was taken to mitigate
the object objections the scheme is now
considered to be acceptable the fact
amendments were made in direct response
to concerns raised is a testament to
this
concerns however still exist regarding
the position of this extension to the
building line and the impact of the
curve of avon crescent which makes it
difficult to establish a straightforward
building line none of the houses take
the line of the curb or form a
continuous acceptable line
the sdp identifies three types of
building line two are displayed in avon
present where paired houses are linked
together but not in continuous line the
paired line is staggered in different
angles relating to the curve of the road
number 26 and number and 28 are paired
set back a meter and at an angle to
number 22 and number 24 also paired
the 45 degree angle used to evaluate
overlooking and loss of amenity does not
cross the proposal footprint as
determined at the outset 30 seconds i
thought a fundamental point in
progressing the scheme further
the roof and ridge are lower the rear
extension is single story to protect
neighbours from overlooking
overshadowing and overbearing the
separation distances comfort conform and
the gap between properties honoured the
materials proposed reflect those already
displayed in conclusion the proposal
meets the guidance of the stratfor
district council's supplementary
planning documents and meets the
council's adopted guidelines the
application is in accordance with the
development plan and with other material
considerations i therefore request that
you grant planning permission as
recommended by your officers thank you
marvelous thank you very much indeed
members do we have do we have any
questions can someone fix that beeping
for me please
do we have any questions for our
applicant and agent
no looks like you covered all bases as
well thank you very much for your time
and contribution this evening if you
wouldn't mind giving the desk a quick
wipe down and sort your hands as well
that'd be great
and while you're doing that council rolf
is next step to cancer off as soon as
there's availability please make your
way forward
are well versed in this you have five
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
otherwise whenever you're sat
comfortable
i wouldn't use as much or as little as
if have it as you like
um whenever you're ready feel free to
stop
uh thank you
um i know some of you must be thinking
well enough i've insisted this comes to
committee
uh let me just explain
the extension is big i've got nothing
against the size of the extension um
i just have a real big concern about the
overbearingness
uh it brings on number 26 avon present
by being so close and forward of the
build line now it's filled with the
build line of number 26 it complies with
the build line of number 24 itself but
imagine a two-story extension coming
even closer to 26.
and being on 24's build line so you're
going to get a meter worth a two-story
meter worth of brick
now interestingly enough the uh planning
officer today drove
up avon crescent had she had driven the
other way along avon crescent
so that way you would have seen
you would have seen how number 24 sticks
out anyway
so you would have seen
that it's not in line and that making it
two-story
and a meter long
you will just see brick uh that's
that is
it's just my concern
um
it doesn't i mean a meter doesn't seem
very very much um but you know as i say
take into account that it's two stories
high and of brick
um
and so it does have an impact on the
curve of the crescent it certainly
doesn't have an impact of the curve
coming the way the planning officer did
today but the other way it does
um
i mean you know i'm not going to get
head up about this i just feel that
you know perhaps a bit more negotiation
should have taken place so that the
extension could have been brought back a
little more
to help with that line of the curve and
not be so overbearing
on number 26 because
as number as the occupant mrs madden
leaves the house she will just see
a meter a two meet a two-story
meter wide brick wall which will affect
her light i mean it just
it just doesn't look
uh well in the street scene thank you
that's rob thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
rolfe councillor curtis
thanks kate um can you tell us how
far because it was on the site visit
this morning this afternoon um
how far
the
new uh wall
will be from the existing front window
of the of number
the the
26 yes thank you oh i don't know i think
the planner will need to to um
we'll get that clarified i mean i would
imagine it's
a meter
meter and a half
any other questions
no in that case kate thank you very much
indeed if you could turn the microphone
off and give the table a quick wipe that
would be great thank you very much
okay uh points clarification for the
officers guess which one we're asking
first lesson
how far away from the window of number
26 is the extension
the window
if you look at the
plan the first part i would make if you
look at the plan on the screen there's a
45
degree line drawn from the front window
so the new extension is not in the 41
degree
could you zoom in on that a bit more
please maybe
okay
yes and that actually could you
sorry now drop it down so we can see the
bull
banished
so we can see
into the road as it were where the road
line is as well
so that's the 45 degree line taken from
the middle of the
window of the habitable room
i don't think the road is on that
picture
hit the
did you have a question yes please um
thanks alison um the extension
the new extension
proposed extension does that sit forward
of the house or back from the
house this is the existing building
yeah and this is the extension
which is
straight line so it's a straight in line
because when
i
went and looked at it um
saturday
there was there was a white truck there
a right side white van and in front of
that was another
car
if that were to come forward would that
then start going on to the pavement i
wonder because they were quite close to
the pavement when i i looked at it so if
if it's because it set it was set back
when the extension is built
there is still space on the drive for
two cars or a car and a van
so when the extension is built it will
be a four bedroomed house so the spg
requires three car parking spaces
so
the officer assessment
rather than have three car parking
spaces within the application site
they've looked at the context
uh
of even present and there's a large
amount of unrestricted car parking
so
would you use one of those
what to park on on the road
yeah
i
i didn't see any when i went there and
it's in the in part on the road okay
thank you any other questions points
clarification members that's
entertainment yeah i listen can you just
clarify that
um
the extension is not going to the
boundary is it
no
there's an existing side access down yes
so
that retains doesn't have to be retained
the other thing
the building line is the front of the
bay window isn't it
this is the bay window here
so
the it's the extension is on the
elevation base yeah
the bay window is where the building
line is because that's the most further
forward of me
um
so you may take it across all the bay
windows but you may decide that they're
not so important to feature you take it
from the wall of the property
um but because there's not a very strong
building line here that's why it's
there's a little bit of doubt where the
building line is some places it would be
much stronger than this yeah okay thank
you
that's the
thank you chairman
i'm
surprised at the situation regarding the
parking so do we have some guidelines
this time often we can actually use
the road to be providing one of our
parking spaces
is are there some guidelines as to which
road times we can use this and which
times we can't
yeah absolutely um
we looked uh against the spd
in terms of how many spaces should be
provided in this case it's three
but only two can be provided
but the default setting isn't meant to
simply refuse you don't have to look as
alison said at the context
and if it's in a location where there's
unrestricted parking
and there's no known particular parking
problems or heightening body highway
safety issues
then it would be acceptable to allow
one of those spaces to be off-site
effectively
that's not to say it would happen
because the owner may only have two cars
and the third one would never rise but
you've considered it in the application
okay unless there any more questions
points clarification let's move into
debate who would like to kick us off
councillor jennings
once i have sympathy for number 26
um obviously a lot of these a lot of the
houses down the road have had lots of
different sized extensions of
so various sizes
to go against um officers decisions
you'd have to have a very you'd have to
have valid planning reasons and there
aren't any valid planning reasons to go
against the officer's decision in this
case in my view i'm happy to propose
that we go along with the office of
recommendation for grant
thank you councillor uh jennings cancer
curtis next please
thank you um i'm just
picking up counselor rolf's
point i think she made about the um
it's a pity there hasn't been perhaps
more negotiation between
the parties
um and looking at the plans
i don't know i mean
we may well end up granting permission
for this but
um
[Music]
good neighborly
uh
so unfortunately it's not for us to
think about good neighborly yeah
whilst i sympathize uh we must make a
decision based on what's put in front of
us um i'm going to second council
jennings proposal for the same reasons i
can't see any planning reason why we
would go against this um the building
line does marry up with the front uh
facade of the existing property there is
a gap between the two whilst it's not
ideal and there is change i have no
planning reasons to go against it so i
am i am seconding would anyone else like
to contribute towards the debate
at this point
casa mills yeah thanks jim i i
i'm just concerned about these car
parking spaces
um because i as i say
the van
at the moment and the car
how their park now is quite tight to the
to the boundary
and if
um
the proposed extension is put in and
that brings it forward um
it will push the car over the paper i'm
sure um you could say you can fit two
cars in there when i looked there were
three cars there
um
the van a car in front of that and a car
by the side of it and how it got in
there i don't know but um that's my
concern um
it's not perfect i don't like it
thank you okay it's not perfect but if
three were in there and you lose a bit
there's probably still going to be two
and as we've heard there is off street
parking the officers have made a full
assessment not ideal i know
would anyone else like to contribute at
this stage to the debate before we move
to a vote
no in that case we'll move to a vote so
the proposal is that has been seconded
is to grant in line with the officer
recommendation could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor
and those against
one chairman and abstentions
in that case committee resolves to
refuse application sorry to oh that was
close
to grant application twenty one zero one
nine eight eight full uh that is 24 even
crescent in stratford-upon-avon
right
members i'm conscious of time uh it is
uh 10 to eight and we have three items
left to get through so um
if we can avoid any repetition i'll be
appreciated um okay so our next item is
uh land south of calico lane and upper
braille the application reference is
21.02452 fu l our presenting officer is
paul thompson who's just getting himself
seated paul as soon as you're ready feel
free to start
yeah good evening
uh we are here in the uh consoles area
of upstanding natural
and today
in the middle of the brailles
this is the application site outlined in
red
uh you give me a name it's a hard g or a
soft g so i'm gonna go with softs julius
lane runs uh
left to right
uh about a quarter of the way down the
street is green and north to south here
is the main road
the red buildings are listed both grade
two
this one here is stone crop which is
a row of all cottages and then
um
this is what's proposed a single
dwelling
roughly central within the plot
with the access onto gillette's lane
which is a probably right of way but
unadopted by county highways
uh we have the view towards stonecraft
here and the view towards enabling
property uh hollywood house
yeah
elevations
to the right of the screen
there
uh this shows jokes like itself you can
see it's very narrow um
this
in the top right corner is the back into
the site through the gap in the head
which is the only change in the site
since we last granted permission for
this in uh 2018 permission
big 2017 permission lapse jewelry
lockdown um they weren't able to
implement here before the entire minute
expired so we are now looking at
precisely the same
uh application as we've seen before the
policy context has not materially
changed although the ndp has since been
adopted um
[Music]
the recommendation therefore is also the
same that's to grant the planning
permission check
paul thanks very much indeed let's call
forward our first speaker on this item
who is counselor louise appleton of
braille's parish council
would you like to make your way forward
do we have counselor appleton here
i'm going to assume that's a no in which
case
would we will call our next speaker who
is ms allison young our agent would you
like to make your way forward
if you cancel that appleton does come in
time we may wear an opportunity but for
the time being
you have three minutes a 30 second
warning whenever you're ready do feel
free to start
good evening i'd like to thank you for
the opportunity to speak on behalf of
the applicant
the planning officer has prepared a
comprehensive report and so do not wish
to take up too much of your time
i do wish however to highlight that this
application is a resubmission of a
scheme approved by committee on the 7th
of march 2018 and that the scheme has
not been changed from that previously
approved
as stated in the committee report the
previous approval unfortunately lapsed
as a result of co-related delays
due to the sale of the site
and a lack of time to discharge the
relevant planning conditions
since the approval of the last
application the ndp has been adopted and
the site is located in the defined built
up area boundary the policy position is
therefore strengthened and the proposal
accords with the housing policies within
the ndp and the course strategy
the proposed dwelling is an attractive
traditional design and appearance the
sighting is in accordance with the
linear pattern of development fronting
at its lane and the dwelling is at an
appropriate height and scale in the
context of the surrounding development
and the hillside setting
with regards to the access there's no
known owner of gillette's lane and the
appropriate certificate of ownership was
submitted with the application an advert
was placed in the newspaper in july with
no owner coming forward therefore the
correct procedural requirements were
followed prior to submitting the
application it's up to the future owner
or developer of the land to take
appropriate legal advice
with regards to the access arrangements
the highway authority has not raised any
objection and access is available for
construction to the rear of the site
like to thank you for your time
thank you very much indeed memphis do
you have any questions for our agents
council andrew serafin hello thank you
um
this application is it the same as the
last one that we're submitting
yes it is okay thank you
okay unless there are any other
questions
no thank you very much for the time
contribution
okay points to clarification of the
offices does anyone have any
no
cancer jennings
our speaker isn't here
any other questions
anyone on to open debate shall i
counselor mills
thanks mr chairman yeah um
you know i looked at this um it is
it's the old application coming again
there's no objections from highways
uh it'd be nice if they put a bungalow
in there because there's a bungalow
opposite um
i can't see any reason why we should
refuse this application mr mr chairman
so i propose we accept
thank you very much
to save you the effort council jennings
i will second that um on the basis that
is identical in always to the previously
agreed one so unless anyone else would
like to speak i propose we go to a vote
all those in favor
that is unanimous so count committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty one zero two four five two full
land south of gillette's lane in upper
brails
marvellous let's move on to our next
item which is application reference
twenty one zero one nine nine six very
that is nuns cottage in elmington again
our presenting conferences paul thompson
paul over to you
thank you chair
we are remaining in the cox wolves and
we are now in illinois
we are just outside the conservation
area which is the purple boundary uh the
red buildings are listed but they
will have no real impact on the
application the dotted green is probably
right away
this is the site plan that we approved
uh back in
2018
um
this
is what it's proposed now says a slight
increase in footprint you can
possibly just make out the orange dotted
lines are those are the original
footprint
and then obviously the white blocks are
a new one and you can see a profusion of
parking spaces this is in response to
the ndp which has also been published
since we last granted permission
the mep specifies one parking space per
bedroom these are three bed properties
so three spaces each
there's also a visitor space uh down on
the
bottom above the site there um because
there are four dwellings that amounts to
0.8 of the visitor space according to
our parking standards we round that up
to 1. uh these are the elevations i've
previously approved quite a
standard issue cockswall cottage
um this is changing uh it's gonna be a
bit taller at the ridge 0.6 meter to be
precise
um a bit bulkier a bit of a difference
of arrangement but again with the uh low
low eaves and whipped eaves at that
there's cotswold stone on the front and
side elevations
uh which is an amendment during the
application process
um
this
is the cottage that was there i think
it's now mostly been demolished i
haven't visited since the the summer but
it was
in ruins when i did it when i did see it
uh that is the view across the site
towards the neighboring property
and under those windows serving a
habitable room to best my knowledge
and that is the view of the street uh
there aren't a great many cocktail
cottages in this part of wilmington um
as you can see the uh drawings on me on
the left hand side there are not all
that far away from the what's being
proposed here as such
my recommendation is to grant permission
for this amendment
paul thank you very much indeed let's
invite our first speaker who is
councillor martin underwood of elmington
parish council good evening and welcome
thank you for your patience
i think you've got an idea of how things
work so you'll have three minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning but
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start
okay sorry
is that can you just check that
microphone is on it's sometimes they
there you go you're on i'll reset your
time
then whenever you're ready do feel free
to start again sorry about that
sorry first of all ill meeting parish
council is very supportive of sensitive
development on this site but objects to
the
variation of this application and indeed
we are disappointed that it's over three
years since permission was first granted
for this development
and the houses have not yet been built
although the old cottage has now been
demolished
and we are very pleased to see the
additional parking recognising the
importance of the neighborhood
development plan
the plan was made in 2021 and had 94
support in the village survey and in
view of the council of the parish
council is that it applies to a hundred
percent of the village
and applying it selectively to different
parts of the village devalues the simple
the substantial effort in local
democracy that was involved in making
this
in the policy cs 2.1 and 2.2 stated
limiting infilling will be accepted if
it contributes positively to the
character of the village and is modest
in proportion of the site size of the
site to design to respect the context
and immunity of the neighbouring
properties of the wider village
and argue these are
not um
satisfied by the current proposal
here i draw the attention to the
committees
to the planning report for development
of the neighbouring property scorpion
house currently under construction
application twenty zero zero one eight
two stroke full
which has not been which is not included
in the pictures you were shown earlier
it's the other way down the street from
the view up the street
and here the planning office report was
i overall consider that the dwelling
will be of a high quality finish using
cotswold materials
and the the design and has has dive
dwelling house design features that
successfully respond to the vernacular
especially the two recently approved
dwellings at nellis cottage the first
pictures you were shown
um
this is not following the uh
the the plan here building is not
following the
ndp
it's specifically it's of the wrong
material it's not a stone it's too large
it's of an inappropriate style an
absolute minimum needs to be finished
with a local stone with appropriate
roofing materials
it increases the substrate at 14
increase in
the footprint
over developed leading to over
development
of the site
and
the very current very generic
contemporary design now design now
detracts from this approach to the
village it's not designed in respect to
the neighbouring property scorpion house
and the rest of the village and
our view is that we should stay with the
original
plans exactly three minutes perfect
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for our counsellor
no
looks like you've covered everything so
counselor thank you very much for your
time and contribution this evening if
you could give the desk a quick white
perfect thank you very much indeed okay
let's call through our next speaker who
is mr dave
circum is that pronounced correctly
perfect do come on down please
okay i think you've probably worked out
how things are going to work so you'll
have three minutes i'll give you 30
second warning whenever you're already
do feel free to start thank you uh my
name is david sirkin with robotims
architects and we're the agents for the
scheme acting on behalf of the applicant
the focus of our discussions today
really are to consider a number of
subjective views relating to the
appearance of the house heights which
are proposed
the design of the consented scheme could
be described as a traditional cotswold
vernacular and is defined largely by the
palette of materials and the form of the
buildings
the consented form incorporates a low
eaves to create a cottage-like
appearance and whilst it is a
characteristic of the area it is not
really in keeping with the context of
development there are no other
properties between the site and front
street which incorporate this feature
notably it is also not a feature of the
recently consented scheme for the single
dwelling referred to next door on the
adjacent site
we therefore don't believe it should be
a necessary characteristic in the design
of the properties which are now proposed
we would refer members to the street
scenes drawings which have been
submitted as part of the application and
which are considered by ourselves and
the officers to be more in keeping with
this part of the village than the
previously consented scheme
with respect to the size of the
dwellings we've calculated the increase
in floor area to be 9
and not 14 as quoted by others
we would consider this change to be both
reasonable and appropriate the footprint
footprint comparison shown on the site
plan indicates that this additional
floor space is provided at the rear of
the properties and is there and
therefore has little or no visual impact
in addition the overall width of the
properties has also been reduced which
further reduces the impact of the
development on the street scene
we know that the height of the dwellings
has been increased but the ridge and
eaves lines of the proposed houses will
be subservient to the adjacent property
and this will ensure the mass is
appropriate when viewed in the street
scenes
there are approximately 19 dwellings
along washbook place between the
application site and front street of
these 19 dwellings only four are faced
with stone and three of these four
incorporate other materials which are
mainly facing brickwork and render
the scheme
so i'm going to i'm going to pause your
time there um do you want to grab that
open it looks like the battery's gone on
you also some we're on joy with tech at
the moment aren't we wonderful i think
it's because it's cold outside
thank you give that one a whirl um
i'll give you an extra 10 seconds for
that um okay you start and then i'll
start my timer okay
the scheme presented proposes the use of
stone to all front and side elevations
every elevation facing the street only
the rear elevations will be in facing
brickwork an approach which is entirely
appropriate and consistent with the
palace of materials used throughout the
village
in summary therefore it is our view that
the proposals presented are reasonable
reflect to comply with the relevant
policy and design guidance and will
significantly enhance this part of the
village as we have heard the proposals
are supported by officers and we hope
that will be supported by members too
didn't need the extra 10 seconds thank
you good man thank you very much uh
members do we have any questions
our agent uh council curtis thanks sir
um
i just wanted to make sure i've got this
right i think because i don't want to
misquote you um i think you said that
the officer considers
this revised style to be more
appropriate to this part of the village
yes i think so i mean i mean through our
discussions we've worked with with
officers throughout the process you know
making tweaks and refining the scheme
and and we i think we're all in
agreement that um
that for this part of the village
certainly looking at the recently
consented scheme for the property next
door that the style that we've adopted
is is is more in keeping with this this
particular street scene than than the
previously consented scheme there are no
there are no examples of that lower
slung eaves line
in in the street scene in this part of
the village
thank you thank you for that clara
council and sarafin thank you
you uh mentioned i know you've extended
the footprint
but that's going backwards
how much have you reduced the width
how much we've reduced the weight
um it's on the approved site plan i i
apologize i don't know the exact
measurement but i i would guess that
they're in the region of about
450 mil width on each side so maybe
maybe close to a meter in in in the
semi-detached block yep okay we'll try
and get some clarification from the
officers on that one do we have any
other questions for our agents
no in that case mr siricom thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening if you give the desk a very
quick wipe we appreciate it
okay um we have no uh registered speaker
from uh councillor fitter so we will
move to
clarification points of officers council
jennings first of all
thank you just want to get a
clarification on the increase in size um
because we've heard that it's 14 or 9
what do you what do you
what's your view on it
can i split the difference and go for 11
and a half
it's not significant is the point
whether whether we take the upper bound
of 14 or the lower of nine i don't
consider that to be a significant
increase
we heard a question from cassandra
seraphin about the uh
reduction in width could you clarify for
us please
that one i can do
[Music]
will be conditioned
yep
technology continues to be recalcitrant
for your peace of mind council jennings
um if you see on page 46
pre-construction conditions number three
is materials just to confirm
sorry to keep you waiting i make it a
reduction of about
2.7 meters if the measurement
function is working correctly there
that's on the the rear two plots parts
three and four
and that's
total reduction sort of shared between
the two of them if you like
uh
i'd say it's
roughly the same at the front without
making you wait another five minutes
it's roughly the same at the front but
it's split between the two plots there
rather than being all on the one plot if
that makes sense
okay thank you very much casa mills
thank you chairman i'm talking about
with the height is it um
higher than the
adjacent properties
i've got that one nailed in that's 0.6
meter so it's just over half a meter
taller
than the adjacent properties yes no it's
slightly shorter it's
great thank you
okay any more points clarification
no less to debate who'd like to kick us
off i'd pick on someone if they don't
have a hand up yeah councillor dixon
i think i'll try and save a bit of time
and i'll propose the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much should put anyone
else casamel's i can second that but um
and we
there's a very nice cotswold stone
that's being developed at the moment but
the other side that there are a mixture
of um
well i think they're all brick actually
um so
yeah i i think it fits in quite well so
our
second camps of dixon thank you i think
i'd agree with that it almost feels like
it's merging from cotswold stone to a
mix of flat and brick and then into
brick
um so i'm so political
wow thank you
would anyone else like to contribute
towards the base
no let's move forward with the vote then
it's been proposed and seconded to grant
in line with recommendation please show
of hands
unanimous therefore uh committee
resolves two blunt application 21.01 996
a very
marvelous our final application for the
evening which is application reference
2102069 ful stratford marina in
stratford-upon-avon are presenting i'm
sorry sarah chadwick as soon as you're
comfortable with sarah please do feel
free to start
sure
and
i should probably declare the interest i
was at the
stratford town council planning meeting
when this was discussed that i come to
this with an open mind
are you on the tower council
are you on the planning committee of
town council yes sure did you vote
you would have voted i don't think if
you it's up to you because at the end of
the day it's your decision-making yeah
i'm slightly uncomfortable yes i think
i'll take your guidance and i'll sit
this out okay good man thank you
thank you chairman this is a full
planning application for a single store
extension to an existing restaurant at
stratford marina
the application site is within the
adopted built-up area boundary of
structure but upon open
and the site is outlined in wreck by the
red line on this plan
the application site is within the town
centre and is also within the
conservation area and an area of
restraint
the restaurant occupies part of the
boathouse which forms part of the wider
marina development grade one listed
clopton bridge is located immediate
immediately to the southwest of the site
and is indicated by the red line on this
plan
the
boathouse building itself dates to the
early 20th century
here we see a proposed floor plan of the
site the proposed extension is forward
projecting another step design with a
flat roof that can be seen at the bottom
of the slide here
here we see proposed elevations of the
development this one from the northwest
with the extension scene on the right
and this one from the southwest with the
extension scene in the foreground on the
left
this image is a cgi
uh image of the proposed extension the
materials are a mixture of aluminium
fascia aluminium frames and a mesh steel
base
this photo is taken from pops and bridge
facing in a north easterly direction
here we can see the north west and
southwest elevations of the building
with the existing raised decking area
and marina in the foreground
this photo is also taken from clopton
bridge but facing in a northwesterly
direction
chairman the principle of development is
acceptable however officers consider
that the proposed development would have
a harmful impact by way of citing a
design on the setting of the grade one
listed clopton bridge contrary to
policies within the development plan
by extension this is considered to cause
harm to the stratfor upon avian
conservation area harm which is not
outweighed by public benefits
harm to the area of restraint has also
been identified the recommendation is
therefore to refuse the application for
the reasons detailed on page 55 of your
agenda
there is one update in the update sheet
referencing one additional third party
comment received thank you sarah thank
you very much indeed one of our first
speakers counselor kevin taylor
who has been patiently waiting since six
o'clock
good evening and welcome i you are very
well versed in what's been happening i'm
sure
whenever you're comfortable it's the one
the one on your left i think is the one
that's working
middle button if it goes red we're good
do you want to yeah we're good okay so
three minutes 30 seconds thank you all
ready good evening everyone
indoor dining restrictions at the start
of the pandemic led to a near collapse
of the restaurant industry as a whole
towns across the country relaxed outdoor
dining regulations to allow makeshift
patio spaces parking spaces and even on
street parking spaces to become
extensions of restaurant dining rooms
here we have an applicant that has the
foresight and vision to create an area
currently underutilized to provide an
area which will create a safe all year
round dining area and assist with
business survival and development
i am here to support this proposal and
the visual improvements it will bring to
this prominent location and the economic
benefits it will bring to this local
business and the town
agreed the clockton bridge is a
wonderful listed structure but i really
don't see that this minor development
will cause harm to its grand setting
which is best viewed from the opposite
side of the marina and from tramway
bridge the river and the recreation
ground
look at the hotel in the background
arguably that causes more harm to the
setting of the clockton bridge
the marina seating and extension is much
lower than the bridge discrete and
perfectly acceptable in my opinion
you can't stagnate development happening
near listed buildings and all too often
automatically think change equals harm
this is the wrong approach in my opinion
this proposal would bring public
benefits to the town by way of an
improved residence and touring tourism
facility in the town centre which will
add to the vibrancy and attraction of
the town and help a long-standing
independent business
well within your time and well worth the
wait um members do we have any questions
for cancer taylor
no
looks like you've covered everything
thank you very much indeed
if you could
it's hot man
having sat there for two and a half
hours
i think you know now okay so our next
speaker is uh mr jeff scoffham scottham
is that pronounced correctly
marvelous do come on down
again you'll have three minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning whenever
you're sat comfortable and ready to go
if you press the button in the middle so
it goes red uh we have another gentleman
coming forward i'm afraid i've only got
uh mrs uh scotland to uh
to speak
i'm afraid not you've not registered
sorry
or members of the local community
the town council support the proposal
i'm stating it brings visual improvement
to this prominent location
historic england trades the application
for the quality of its inherited
statement they find no harm in the
schedule of monument
bridge
have no objections to their own heritage
furthermore there are several public
benefits
it provides a space that reflects
government requirements for
well-ventilated restaurants
now we
all the windows will drop down to value
straight height and roof lights open to
use natural ventilation not relying on
lives planned the roof lights
incidentally are flat roof lights
diners can look at the schedule of
ancient monuments from the extension
whereas most whereas most visitors
distracted only see the tarmac when they
grow drive over the bridge
however i do not rely on the public
benefits just by the approval and the
proposal the approval
um proposals do not harm heritage assets
and it represents good delight
the design is simple usually steel
cladding aluminium and glass to reduce
the impact and subservient to the
existing building and will contrast
through the surrounding marina and
clumpton bridge
this design approach has been accepted
by
historic england on numerous occasions
relating to extensions to the listed
buildings which is buildings
when you see this site from clonton
bridge
footpath the grand plaza dominates the
backdrop with this very large industrial
entrance cabinet
the building is staggered to reflect the
shape of the marina and it's accessed up
and respect the other uses of the
building
the aluminium mesh preventing debris
though blowing underneath or washing
under the building
was a requirement for the raised decking
by the environment agency and approved
by yourselves
on the refurbishment of the existing
building
the use of natural ventilation
heat recovery ventilation from kitchens
and the existing protocol tanks fell on
the roof of the existing building and
sold again in the lower winter sun
will all help the energy sustainability
within schools
30 seconds
building looks much better than the
rover's pallets right in decking and
umbrellas intense currently used
i refer you to the photographs and now
on the cgi
and conclude i disagree with the
assessment of the planning officer
regarding the impact of the heritage
asset
the absolute apollo judgement of the
town council in south england
thank you very much members do you have
any questions counseling seraphim
thank you
um would this development increase
employment
yes
it would okay thank you any other
questions
no mr gotham thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening and
thank you for your patience as well
okay members points of clarification to
officers councilman mills i think he's
got a question
thank you mr chairman um
can you tell me the distance from the
clemson bridge to
the development for this proposed
application
i can and the existing building is 38
meters from clockton bridge and the
extension is 9.2 meters in depth so
129 meters if the extension
okay
thank you
councillor dixon
uh are we happy that the cgi represents
what is being proposed accurately and if
you are happy that that is correct can
we have this shot of i think it was the
same establishment but with the the
awnings because i want to are those
awnings in the place to be replaced by
what is being proposed is it basically
the same place
to answer your first question i would
say
in my opinion it fairly represents
what's proposed yeah the materials the
sighting and the
overall design
um sorry and then to answer your second
question
um as you'll be aware lots of businesses
have taken advantage of the relaxation
permitted development rules and search
for
umbrellas and awnings
um
it's my understanding that the extension
would replace what's there at the moment
any other questions members
no let's move to the debate who wants to
kick us off cancer mills
thanks mr chairman yeah um i mean
looking at the uh looking at with the
awnings um it looks a bit more untidy
than the proposed application
um it's going to increase uh employment
um
i think it looks pretty good myself mr
chairman so i'm in favor of supporting
the application thank you is that a
proposal yeah it can be yeah just bear
in mind we do need to have clear reasons
to go
to overturn the two recently yeah so
i'll come back to you for those council
jennings
thank you
um cgi i think it looks absolutely great
um
i
obviously the public benefits in my view
over
outlay any outweigh any harm the
economic benefits
um the increase in employment
increase in tourism offer especially
with the riverside development
and which all ties in there um
i'll be very happy to second the
proposal
fabulous anyone else likes to contribute
can i said
see if it feeds back me
um i i agree with councillor jennings
and mills to be fair um i do i do think
it does enhance the character of the
area country to the report and i don't
think that it's necessarily a poor
design i think it looks great and i do
think it
would make a valuable addition to the
town
marvelous thank you very much anyone
else before i try and sum up the reasons
to go against officer's recommendation
i'd better do that then
i think it's fabulous it looks great
isn't it what a wonderful modern take uh
that will allow people to appreciate and
enjoy
uh a fabulous bridge i mean superb so
that is one reason why uh i think the
committee would agree uh we would go
against um there's the public benefit or
the benefit of that uh that we believe
oh my god i'm not getting my structure
right here am i at all
do you want me to come on what i've
heard lots of different you can do it
sounds to me
like you're not going to need public
benefits because you don't seem to it
doesn't look like anyone's found any
harm here so you don't even get to that
first threshold from what i've heard
was the word that i was tripping over
for some reason but then obviously we
have the better
substantial harm it sounds like certain
committee members have said there's no
harm and if that's the case you don't
need public benefits
i think we're agreed on that um are we
yeah
are you happy with that and we can go to
a vote yeah in that case let's go to a
vote so the reasons given
conditions
um we've got
we've got a condition standard condition
for three years standard condition for
approved plans
materials to match as per the approved
puns a condition for the sample of the
mesh
and then there's two notes one about the
mppf standard and one about the
environment agency for how that mesh is
managed in the event of flood
okay perfect
uh in that case members you've heard the
conditions we have a proposal to grant
for the reasons given can i have a share
of hands for those in favor please
unanimous marvelous in that case
committee results to grant application
21 0 2 0 6 9 full stratford marina on uh
bridge foot and strapping upon avon um i
don't believe there is any other
business or any urgent business no in
that case members at 23 minutes past
eight we will call it a meeting to a
close thank you very much for your help
and contribution